max was sagst du zu dem laien tisch von
geo gute frage weil ich bin nicht so 100
prozent hinter doch es geht hier soll
kran ii und ich reite heute longboard
mit meinem rasanter und wir haben es
hier weil ich gut ein ice und ein
erfrischungsgetränk und jetzt werden wir
ein bisschen rum cruisen und bei dem
stellenwert da dachte ich mir wieder mal
so ein typisches frage antwort video und
yahoo
ach ja
was ist es
jede
so leute da sind jetzt auch wieder zu
hause angeschaut und der burg gewählt
werden hierbei wir sind hinter der burg
güssing war das zu einer skala von eins
bis drei im 18 kommentare ihr wisst ja
der boy ist kreativ laut der bdh kreativ
wie kein anderer was seine video ideen
angeht deshalb dass mir heute über
fragen und keine ahnung
vorher lesen und beantworten
stimmt wenn ihr wollt dass ich das nicht
wissen
der hashtag unter der brücke habe ich
mich auch täuschen
hast du schon mal hashtag unter der
brücke geschlafen habe ich noch nicht
aber ich fand es ganz schön hier und da
ein bisschen was anderes als sonst immer
die buchten wo wir sind
max was sagst du zu dem laien tiscon
gute frage weil ich bin nicht ständig zu
100 prozent hinter also erst mal
musikalisch nichts aufregendes für mich
hast du ja auch an dann kann's nicht
reden aber ich es musikalisch nicht
besonders aufregend fand ich das von
fortune glaube ich dass er auch
aufgesprungen
kann ich noch ein bisschen cooler aber
es war echt nicht zu besonderes fand ich
also einmal das und dann diese ganze
schien es war nicht so in sich ja
irgendwie und so von wegen
ist mir ganz egal was sie macht aber
wenn ihr apple bleibe ich halt deine
freundin mit kann ich nicht so 100 es
war interessant anzuhören
aber es wird ein bisschen über haid
findet also hat mich die ganze
aufmerksamkeit verdient finde ich habe
mehr aufmerksamkeit verdient oder so
nächste frage hersteller brücke willst
du mal deine haare färben piercings
tattoos etc ist ja aktuell sehr beliebt
das zu machen
ich will mir nicht so sicher dass das
also hart werden vielleicht wenn ich das
irgendwann mal machen und spätestens
wenn ich glaube
aber piercings tattoos piercings und
tattoos finde ich noch am coolsten von
diesen ganzen sachen aber ich würde mir
nichts permanentes machen lassen weil
ich weiss nicht mehr verändert sich so
schnell und es kann einfach sein dass
man das in ein paar jahren so was von
uncool finden was man sich da auch
tätowieren lassen hat dass ich da nichts
dauerhaftes machen wollte was mir schon
überlegt habe es irgendwie so eine art
händler oder airbrush oder wie auch
immer das heißt und tattoo das finde ich
noch ganz cool so zumindest mal aus dem
checken ob mir das steht oder ob das
cool ist oder so was
aber so ein permanentes tattoo ist schon
eine ziemlich ziemlich krasse sache also
also da würde ich mir wenn etwas
winziges tätowieren lassen oder sogar
durch wird mir hier sind einen punkt ein
muttermal gratulieren lassen und dann
kann ich ihnen sagen ich habe mich aber
weiter auf mich selbst verhält es gar
nicht weil ich ich habe kein motiv
lebensmotto
die augenbrauen wenn das jemand in
photoshop machen kann weiß
deutschlandbild dafür und dann
beantworten wir die nächste frage magst
du nur im keller oder wohnst du auch da
gut aufpasst weiß dass ich immer da im
keller chile wenn ich aufnehme da bin
ich also mein zimmer ist oben erstmal
dazu schon mal aber dann bin ich immer
mal runter gegangen
der lauf nacht aufnehmen kann weil sonst
musste ich immer um 8 wurde sowas ja
ruhig sein als meine kleinen schwester
schlafen gegangen ist und und ja also
ich wohne nicht im keller in ihm da
unten nur auf und mein zimmer ist das wo
ich immer meine videos eigentlich
anfangen wenn ich sind nicht so wie
heute irgendwo anders anfangen richtig
coole frage hier von mattia unser fragt
er
maxim ethik das kokain mit der das nicht
kennt das aus eine manipulierte und
kochen sie wirklich uns wirklich
ernsthaft zu beantworten
ich mag genetik von video ganz cool
hughes hat die siesta verbüßt haben
ich habe kein coupé mit sowie lange
fährst du schon longboard und spielst du
ein instrument
ich fahre longboards wie dann fahre ich
long bot dann hast du mir das hier
verkauft
schon länger hat sich youtube machte
meine und ein instrument spielt ich
nicht aktiv ich habe gespielt aber ich
glaube davon kann ich gar nichts mehr
das war auch mehr so an meinen eltern
dass sich das gespielt habe längst
selber noch heute dokumentiert aber es
geht wieder zurück von einem 2 zu hause
unter der brücke zu meinem richtigen
zuhause
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen freunde
und dann sind wir nicht mal wieder ich
weiß nicht wie lange geworden ist aber
ich hoffe alles hat gepasst
auf jeden fall etwas wo ich lust drauf
hatte dieses video jetzt zu machen wegen
der schönen wetter und so und wissen
noch was sagen auch dass das letzte wort
vielen dank herr für ein geschenk